[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 alors
que la tension monte entre la russie et
l'otan à propos d'une invasion
éventuelle de l'ukraine des
représentants russes ukrainiens
allemands et français se réunissent en
format normandie à paris une première
depuis plus de six mois alors que la
russie multiplie les manoeuvres
militaires à la frontière de l'ukraine
emmanuel macron doit avoir une
conversation téléphonique avec vladimir
poutine vendredi les états unis ont
remis la réponse écrite à moscou il n'y
aura pas de changement dans la politique
d'ouverture de l'otan affirmé anthony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mais washington s'attend
toujours à ce que la russie puisse faire
usage de la force militaire contre
l'ukraine d'une manière ou d'une autre
peut-être avant la mi-février a déclaré
la vice secrétaire d'état américaine
wendy sherman alors jusqu'où ira
l'escaladent quels sont les intérêts de
chacun relancer ce format normandie est
il un premier palier vers une
désescalade on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
alexandre orlov ancien ambassadeur russe
en france bonsoir à vous monsieur
l'ambassadeur merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous ambassadeurs donc en france de 2008
à 2010 est avec nous également bonsoir
volodymyr peaucelle ski président de l'
ong ukraine en europe enseignants à
l'inalco bonsoir et bienvenue également
le soir nous avons passe par skype de
paris avec nous bruno tertrais bonsoir
bruno tertrais directeur adjoint de la
et vert frs merci d'être avec nous
bonsoir en duplex de bruxelles avec nos
également bernard guetta eurodéputés la
république en marche le groupe renew
membre de la commission des affaires
étrangères membre également de la
délégation à la commission de
coopération parlementaire union
européenne et russie bonsoir bernard
guetta et bienvenue également à vous
bon soit vous nous aurons également en
direct d'ukraine notre correspondant
gulliver craag avant de démarrer cette
discussion jour dès qu'on écoute tout de
suite anthony blinken c'était il ya très
peu de temps le chef de la diplomatie
américaine qui s'est exprimée
le document que nous avons remis inclut
les interrogations des états unis et des
alliés concernant les actions de la
russie qui minent la sécurité mais aussi
une évaluation générale
pragmatique des interrogations russe
avec nos réponses concernant des sujets
sur lesquels nous pouvons avoir un
terrain d'entente mais nous avons été
clairs sur les sujets que nous soutenons
et défendons la souveraineté de
l'ukraine et son intégrité territoriale
ainsi que le droit des états de choisir
eux mêmes leurs accords de défense et
leur alliance alexandre orlov la
souveraineté de l'ukraine donc elle est
souveraine c'est ukraine c'est ce que
dit anthony blinken on viens de
l'entendre poutine va t-il faire usage
de la force en ukraine en février à la
mi février le 4 le 18 février bah
écoutez unis en février n'ya marcigny
après moi je crois qu'il faudrait donner
quand même un peu une autre lecture à la
crise que nous vivons aujourd'hui et
c'est pas une crise entre la russie et
l'ukraine mais c'est la crise entre la
russie et le temps la russie et les
etats unis d'amérique
ce que nous voulons éviter c'est la
reproduction de la crise de cuba de 1962
est-ce qu'on évite polytechnique est
peut-être encore panet c'est dans tous
les livres d'histoire c'est très bien
très bien et alors vous savez que nous
voyons que depuis des années les temps
l'otan se rapproche de nos frontières
nous voyons aussi la rhétorique très
agressive de la part des états unis de
l'otan et nous craignons tout simplement
que les missiles nucléaires américains
seront installés tout près de chez nous
et ils vont menacer avec un talent d'un
grand intendant vol de cinq minutes
alors je crois que donc ça vous le
craignez ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
maintenant il m'a nommé nous savons vous
savez les russes sont très forts aux
échecs nous savons contrairement à
certains autres calculer les coûts en
avance et nous voyons où va le temps
c'est pour ça que poutine a justement
pour éviter
que nous soyons place est vraiment au
bord d'une nouvelle guerre mondiale a
dit signons des accords prenons des
engagements formels juridique pour ne
pas mettre l'autre côté pendant jeu de
mots il est dit en déployant cent mille
soldats à la frontière ne viennent pas
du tout pas du tout
d'alluré sion non d'abord d'abord la
russie peut faire sur son territoire
sont propres au territoire ce qu'il veut
oui mon fallait la frontière olic alors
un tel horaire ce que nous craignons ce
que nous craignons que vous savez bien
une autre aspect qui est très important
ce qui se passe aux etats unis
d'amérique
vous savez que la cote de popularité du
baden est au plus bas il veut remonter
sa cote part une petite guerre un petit
lumière c'est lui qui venait en face du
dit me
et reproduire le scénario de 2008 en
géorgie pousser les ukrainiens à
reprendre par la force d'une basse
provoquer la réussite puisqu'à dons
passés il ya des mines de dizaines de
milliers de gens qui parlent le russe
qui sont russes
après m'être de nouvelles sanctions
contre la russie c'est ça son calcul
justin nous ne voulons pas du tout
attaquer le crains que là aucun intérêt
à attaquer ce pays juste une question et
après je vais réagir notre autre invité
mais ça va pas c'est à dire pourquoi
vladimir poutine veut-il revenir à 1997
année justement de l'entrée d'un certain
nombre de pays de l'est dans l'otan on
sait très bien c'est inacceptable pour
pour les états unis d'écouté ne peut pas
être une base en fait de travail
diplomatique
si au moment de la réunification de
l'allemagne il ya encore des témoins qui
sont vivants on peut les interroger qui
ont participé à des négociations entre
gorbatchev et à l'époque les américains
c'était le jazz becker qui est le
secrétaire d'état hélas les américains
ont dit écouter s'il ya la réunification
de l'allemagne le temps va pas
progresser son infrastructure militaire
au delà des frontières de l'allemagne
nous voyons ce qui s'est passé depuis et
aucune promesse formelle non non c'était
fait oralement c'était faudra le
mouiller
n'a pas reconnu après il a parlé de ça
il a dit que non c'est pas non pas du
ciel européen un coup d'état là moi je
suis ami de roland dumas oui un homme
qui était ministre des affaires
étrangères de la france et qui a
participé à ces négociations et cogent
cher il a confirmé ouvertement que ces
engagements oraux ont été données ok
c'est pas le sujet
qui
veut faire pitié s'il veut recréer d'une
manière artificielle les conditions dans
lesquelles se trouve l ukraine en
septembre 2014 en janvier février 2015
ou sous la menace le dif est militaire
les autorités ukrainiennes ont dû
accepter les accords minsk and the core
mise l'eau donc aujourd'hui ceux qui
vous critiquent aujourd'hui aussi en
négociations qui sont en cours
ce qu'il veut c'est que l'ukraine
accepte de négocier directement avec les
soi disant dirigeants des répliques
autoproclamé de nier ce qui lui reste qu
il veut que l'ukraine que donc ce qu'il
va faire et pas seulement félin 10 et
l'ukraine c'est à dire que lui avec
cette exigence que l'ukraine
n'accèdent jamais à le temps mais aussi
vos bosnie c'est le cas c'est à dire de
rendre l'ukraine de faire de l'ukraine
deux fédérations un gouvernant bel à
l'instar de bosnie ça l'objectif de
poutine et on voit bien que l'ukraine
que cette exigence de négociations
indirectes on voit bien que c'est le cas
ne peux pas accepter est-ce que c'est
ces
marionnettes de ses
dirigeants autoproclamés ils sont des
marionnettes mais on va revenir sur le
donbass entre ce qui est le président et
craignent à l'huile évoque une invasion
de cardiff par exemple la deuxième ville
ukrainienne à 30 kilomètres de la
frontière c'est un scénario je me sens
je pense que à ce moment heureusement ça
sur ce point je suis d'accord il n'y a
pas assez de force mais l'est-elle russe
pour envisager une attaque frontale et
en plus ce n'est pas l'objectif de
dellus l'élu ce qu'ils veulent
comprendre ce qu'ils veulent faire
comprendre à tout le monde que and
ukraine et là une guerre civile
et donc s'il y a aussi attaqué
directement l'ukraine donc tout ce
discours
ne sera plus crédible mais ce que
reproche également la russie l ukraine
c'est que réalise elle souhaite rentrer
dans le temps mais c'est le mess il a
aussi dit que mais c'est le sourire
l'eau c'est le souhait de l'ukraine
on peut pas on ne vit pas dans le 19ème
xviie siècle avec des zones d influence
le problème de la russie qui se comporte
t-il toujours c'est ivre de son
impérialisme chauvinisme digne du 19e
siècle et se comporte ainsi donc si les
l'ukraine vont adhérer a le temps c'est
son droit comme c'était le droit les
pays-bas être roi de la pop dans
d'autres pays c'est le cas non monsieur
l'ambassadeur l'ukraine veut adhérer à
l'otan priori c'est ça la souveraineté
d'un état on écoutait on peut pas
contester le droit de piloter des réaux
pas dans le temps oui mais ce que nous
disons que attention si le cren adhère
dans le temps il y aura des conséquences
très graves
non pas par le crème mondiale l'ukraine
les raids de l'otan sans donner moi dans
ce jeu dans ce jeu jeu politique le cren
c'est une monnaie des changes mais ce
sont les états unis estime qu'ils vont
payer leur sécurité alors justement
parlons des européens qui vont payer
leur sécurité bernard guetta il ya une
démarche et d'emmanuel macron qui veut
aller vers une désescalade la france et
l'allemagne qui ont affiché tout de même
leur unité face à la russie du côté tout
de même des américains plus ce format
normandie qui est ouvert aujourd'hui à
paris un kir donc unis les russes les
ukrainiens les allemands les français
justement sur cette question du don
bassesse qui a une possibilité de
désescalade
bernard guetta ou est-ce qu emmanuel
macron fait preuve de naïveté
écoutez à votre question c'est monsieur
poutine et lui seul qui peut répondre
sur la possibilité de désescalade
et je ne crois pas que de la part du
président macron il y ait une naïveté a
tenté d'activer ou de réactiver tous les
canaux diplomatiques possibles
évidemment qu'il faut faire cela
évidemment qu'il faut donner une chance
à la paix d'un côté et de l'autre côté
nous préparer à prendre au cas où
monsieur poutine aurait la très mauvaise
idée très mauvaise idée pour l'ukraine
très mauvaise idée pour la stabilité du
continent europe et très mauvaise idée
pour la russie pour son propre régime et
pour la propre pérennité de sa
présidence au cas donc où monsieur
poutine aurait la très mauvaise idée
d'envahir tous tous partie de l'ukraine
il faut immédiatement des sanctions non
seulement européenne mais américaine
puisse tomber et que dans leur j'entends
pas trois semaines après et que ces
sanctions soient
extraordinairement sévère on parle de
l'exclusion de la russie du cim système
swift c'est une possibilité en tout cas
elle n'est pas du tout exclu dans les
couloirs du parlement européen je peux
vous le dire on parle de sanctions
personnelles prises contre les
principales figures de l'entourage
direct de monsieur poutine et on parle
même de sanctions de prises directement
contre monsieur poutine lui même dont on
dit que les avoirs à l'étranger ne sont
pas masse mais vous allez je voudrais
revenir sur une chose que disait
l'ambassadeur orlov il disait et je m'en
réjouis beaucoup je me réjouis beaucoup
d'avoir entendu cela que non non non il
n'est pas question d'envahir l'ukraine
mais de parler de des préoccupations de
sécurité de la russie en europe 1 très
bien parlons moi j'en suis à nardant
partisans parlons des préoccupations de
sécurité de la russie puisqu'elle dit en
avoir mais je voudrais faire observer à
monsieur orlov et à travers lui à
monsieur poutine que les cent mille
soldats qui sont à la frontière de
l'ukraine et qui crée un trouble c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire dans tout le
continent européen ce ne sont pas des
soldats de l'alliance atlantique mais de
la fédération de russie je voudrais
faire observer à monsieur orlov que
l'alliance atlantique et aucun de ces
pays n'a un excès un centimètre carré de
territoires en europe alors que la
fédération de russie à un excès en
quelques semaines la crimée et
entretient avec armes et argent forces
armées forces argent une
tentative de sécession de toute
l'ukraine orientale alors nous aussi
monsieur l'ambassadeur nous avons des
préoccupations de sécurité et si nous
devons parler d'eux préoccupations de
sécurité parlons des vôtres parlons des
autres et peut-être arriverons nous à
une stabilisation du continent ce serait
en tout cas souhaitable beaucoup plus
souhaitable qu'une invasion de l'ukraine
bruno tertrais justement avant de faire
réagir monsieur l'ambassadeur à ce que
vient de dire bernard guetta est ce que
justement c'est une guerre que souhaite
joe biden comme viennent de le dire
alexandre orlov
c'était la dernière chose
d'avoir une vue manière franchement si
vous voyez qu'il n'est pas suffisamment
occupé avec le co vide et par ailleurs
que sa préoccupation stratégique numéro
un n'est pas l'asie et la chine beaucoup
plus que l'europe et en russie je crois
qu'il faut regarder les choses il faut y
aller chausser à peu près la dernière
chose
celui ci pendant entendre que je
raisonne pourrait vouloir une guerre non
franchement c'est pas sérieux a rappelé
que les mesures lorsque nous dit que le
problème c'est que c'est l'otan moi ce
que je constate c'est que les 100 ou 120
mille hommes de l'armée russe elle se
retire de l'ukraine c'est un
2e 2e quoi la référence à cuba à la
crise de cuba est extrêmement étrange
car les pays de l'otan se sont engagés
unilatéralement de la rochelle pour
assurer justement la russie à la fin des
années 90 en disant jamais nous mettrons
d'armes nucléaires sur les pays d'europe
centrale et orientale qui sont les
nouveaux membres de l'otan c'est un
engagement unilatéral nous prenons et je
peux vous dire par ailleurs qu'aucun
ville au temps le temps ça fonctionne
par consensus même si l'amérique on est
le leader aucun ville hôte en a envie
d'avancer comme ça les armes nucléaires
près de près des frontières de la russie
enfin pardon mais je voudrais quand même
redire là encore ça a été dit ces
derniers jours beaucoup de gens mais que
le récit était fait par l'ofs et pour
parler 10,4 plus
unification allemande des pales du tout
le récit historique et que chacun peut
constater dans les archives sont
maintenant est classifié il n'y a jamais
eu de promesse mais morale
lui terminé jean par la seule promesse
qui a été faite chacun peut le constater
les archives so et à sifié c'est ne pas
placer de force de l'otan sur le
territoire de l'ex allemagne orientale
promesse faite promesse tenue tout le
reste c'est du révisionnisme historique
alexandre orlov avait assez rapidement
et ils voudraient qu'on avance également
dans le débat dans écoutez moi j'écoute
beaucoup d'histoires ils se sont
vraiment c'est n'importe quoi alors les
fameuses too prusse à la frontière avec
l'ukraine encore une fois même s'il 100
mille soldats et même maintenant écouter
et coûteux l'état major crimes a dit
qu'ils ne voient pas des préparatifs de
guerre de la part de la russie contre
l'ukraine a parfois il nous est parfois
il est certes nettement mieux que bourg
madame
d'autre part nos soldats sont sur notre
territoire
alors la frontière lac l'ukraine et 3000
de kilomètres de pain pourquoi les
déployer la pardonnez moi nous avait
envoyé ses troupes en roumanie mais pour
quoi faire cette annonce justement
souligné allons sur notre territoire
faut pas faire le crochet dans non
pourquoi les déployer à la frontière il
ya bien une attente sur la 112 l'admirer
6 nous craignons justement des
provocations et les lipides le temps des
américains poussent le craignent à faire
la guerre contre d'une basse et contre
la russie soyons pas naïfs vous répondez
je sais dessus et on va revenir au mans
sur le don bart ouvry russie tout le
monde menace la russie en puissance
atomique le pays le plus grand du monde
c'est au contraire on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui pour parvenir à une paix de
l'europe par part soit disant un traité
global entre deux puissances et aux
dépens des intérêts des polonais des
italiens de l'ue s'est déjà passé de
l'histoire plusieurs fois savent ça
passera plus il use doivent comprendre
ça il n'arrive pas à comprendre ce
qu'ils craignent les re finalement
qu'une sorte de démocratie en ukraine
c'est ça qu'ils craignent
c'est important mais assez coûteuse la
voici n'a jamais été contre les
décisions de l'ukraine et l'union
européenne au rapprochement avec
l'europe la russie est contre l'adhésion
de l'ukraine dans le temps un bloc
militaire qui est ouvertement proclamé
la russie sur l'ennemi c'est tout à fait
compréhensible mais là on va on va
revenir sur justement la situation dans
le don de base puisque vous en parlez
beaucoup vladimir poser le ski après je
vous fait réagir injuste on va on va
regarder ce petit sujet qui va permettre
au téléspectateur aussi de comprendre ce
qui se passe justement dans le donbass
depuis toutes ces années
à 200km à l'est la russie prépare ses
chars
à 170 kilomètres au nord l'armée
ukrainienne veille dans ces tranchées
et entre les deux donetsk villes de
l'est de l'ukraine contrôlée par les
séparatistes pro russes en guerre contre
kiev depuis huit ans
maxime et dan il avait une dizaine
d'années quand la guerre a commencé
je suis fatigué de cette situation le
conflit n'a pas de sens on sait même pas
pourquoi la guerre continue pré-national
oui bien sûr je veux partir parce qu'ici
je n'ai pas de perspective il n'y a
aucun moyen de prendre son envol si
durant la journée la vie à l'air normal
la nuit la ville est déserte
donetsk est sous couvre feu depuis 2014
l'indépendance autoproclamée de la
région n'est reconnue par aucun pays y
compris la russie la jeunesse de donetsk
vie presque enfermé moi je vous pouvez
sortir du pays pour des vacances mais
vous devez réunir un tas de documents et
il n'est même pas acquis qu'ils
voulaient seront partis relie même
revenir dans certains quartiers les
traces de la guerre sont présentes en
vie tant le conflit a fait treize mille
morts et l'année dernière le service
militaire est devenue obligatoire pour
les jeunes
berlinguer taille est justement une
reprise de ce format normandie c'est à
dire négociations entre l'ukrainien
russe français allemand aujourd'hui à
paris c'était en fait ce format
normandie existe depuis justement que ce
qu'il fallait devait mettre en place ce
qu'on appelle les accords de minsk qui
ont été mis en place ensuite non
appliquée ou pas qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de ce format normandie bernard
guetta
écoutez je ne sais pas si on peut en
attendre
j'en doute un petit peu je ne sais pas
si on peut en attendre quelque chose
dans l'immédiat mais en revanche c'est
certainement un bon signe que ces quatre
pays
russie ukraine france et allemagne et pu
se réunir et que donc que monsieur
poutine ne se soit pas opposé à cette
réunion mais si vous me permettez je
voudrais rebondir sur ce que disait
monsieur orlov tout à l'heure en lui
disant tout de même que je suis assez
surpris pour ne pas dire stupéfait et
connaissant le professionnalisme des
diplomates russes et le connaisseur
depuis 35 ou 40 ans de l'entendre dire
sans rire qu'il y aurait des troupes
russes à la frontière de l'ukraine parce
que la russie craindrait une agression
de l'ukraine la russie craint que le
languedoc vincent entrer ses troupes sur
le territoire russe et nationaux l'otan
commencé longtemps l'otan n'est pas en
ukraine monsieur l'ambassade si le lien
de g
dp de le temps que sera le cren etc et
prépare les parts dans ses réserves
monsieur abbas est ça qui prépare les
ukrainiens attaqué la russie sans la mer
soit même soyons sérieux alors je vous
répète une chose rudy relance valiant se
réunir et un risque de haut
voilà je vais vous le dire au risque de
vous flatter encore une fois je connais
trop le professionnalisme des diplomates
russes pour ne pas conclure non
seulement de notre conversation à
l'instant mais des conversations que
j'ai eues
par ailleurs que véritablement il y a en
ce moment un immense et profond malaise
au ministère russe des affaires
étrangères
devant
l'aventurisme totale du président
poutine
bruno tertrais pour rebondir justement
sur les états unis il ya eu cette
réponse écrite il n'y a pas très
longtemps il ya quelques minutes cette
réponse écrite de washington à moscou et
c'est ce qu'attendait moscou une réponse
écrite on n'en sait pas beaucoup plus
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que anthony
blinken elle dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
changement sur la politique d'ouverture
de l'otan est ce que cette réponse
écrite peut effectivement être une base
diplomatie de discussions avec la russie
ou est-ce qu au contraire parce que
justement anthony blinken vient de dire
que l'otan ne changeait pas de position
sur sa politique d'ouverture ça veut
dire derrière conflit
une réponse mais deux réponses qui sont
attendus l'une des états unis l'autre de
l'otan puisque la russie a proposé de
traiter en fait en forme d'ultimatum
puisque ce sont des exigences à prendre
ou à laisser le ministère des affaires
étrangères russe justement l'a très bien
dit et donc il n'est pas question
évidemment de ces derniers n'étaient
mason qui reviendrait renier tous les
engagements que nous tous pays européens
et américains russie comprise avant prix
en 1990 sousse ensemble de laisser
chaque état souverain en europe choisir
l'alliance dans laquelle il veut être ou
ne pas être donc évidemment on ne va pas
revenir là dessus monsieur linken vers
le 10e et l'otan mais ça ne veut pas
dire du tout qu'on est qu'on est pressé
de d'intégrer l'ukraine dans l'otan je
ne sais même pas d'ailleurs s'il traîne
entre rageant dans le temps ce qui n'est
pas concevable celle qu'un état quel
qu'il soit russie comprise exerce un
chantage sur la liberté la souveraineté
des pays européens et les états unis
alors à partir de là qu'est ce qui se
passe là il ya des choses dont on peut
discuter évidemment moi je suis pour la
diplomatie comme tout le monde viasat
manque d'idées ils sont proposés par les
américains les européens sur les mesures
de confiance leader sur l'avenir de la
maîtrise des armements notamment le
contrôle des armements des missiles à
moyenne portée y compris nucléaire ça ce
sont des choses dont on policiers j
avais donc on doit discuter il n'y
croyez une des premières discussions il
y a quinze jours entre russes et
américains en tronçon et russes ça va se
poursuivre mais en tout cas la réponse
le type atom double team attend de la
russie est évidemment un double non pas
seulement la part des états unis mais
aussi de tous les paysans bien qu'il
assure ses couleurs sont très solidaires
isère les autres et justement alexandre
orlov là on apprend également que le
chef des de l'eau tandis qu'ils
demandent justement une désescalade un
lui aussi avait fait une réponse écrite
à la russie est ce que la diplomatie pas
encore empêcher un conflit allègrement
je suis étonné que ce monsieur convient
d'attendre a déjà vu la réponse des
américains que personne n'a encore vu
sauf pour mener ses affaires étrangères
de la russie mais ce qu'ils voudraient
revenir je voudrais revenir aux accords
du musc puisque si on veut avoir une
désescalade
il faut faire appliquer ces accords qui
en effet c'est le 12 février 2015 par le
président porochenko avec justement les
représentants d'une basse
et qui cet accord était garantie par la
france l'allemagne et la russie et ce
qui est en jeu c'est la crédibilité de
la france et de l'allemagne en tant que
pays garants puisque depuis sept ans
rien n'a été fait pour faire exécuter
ces accords où se trouve la solution
juste la solution des trucs sable le
premier atout c'est justement la
solution c'est quoi le nom aussi de la
solution alors les dés sont les éléments
clés des accords de musc c'est la
reconnaissance d'un statut spécial de
cette région qui est historiquement un
régions de la russie où les gens parlent
le russe
c'est leur langue maternelle
ils veulent parler leur langue
maternelle
avoir un statut spécial au sein de la
russie et d'ailleurs je voudrais
rappeler à des gens qui ont une mémoire
courte que en 2014 lapsus ou lyon vous
vouliez dire en même temps
même temps le référendum en crimée il a
eu le référendum à dole basse où les
gens ont demandé leur attachement à la
russie et monsieur poutine a dit non
vous devez rester au sein de la rue de
l'ukraine d'ailleurs elle a été dit dans
l'hérault partage que la russie n'a pas
reconnu l'adena l ona nous voulons que
dans basterds est à l'intérieur de
l'ukraine mais que les droits des gens
qui vit où là bas soit garantie par le
club c'est tout ce que nous voulons vous
voulez dire poser ce qu'est ce que vous
pouvez répondre est reçue c'est vrai
qu'on parle beaucoup des accords de
minsk alors chacun se renvoie un peu la
balle sur qui n'appliquent pas ces
jacques
chirac ont été signés sous la menace
cela de la défaite militaire de
l'ukraine l'ukraine accepté ces
conditions et mais là aussi le premier
point de ces 2,5 en 2011 qu'il faut en
revenir à ce qu'il faut ce qui n'était
jamais été le cas ou quoi parce que la
russie veut comprendre que l et les
parties est en vie que ces soi-disantes
autorités de deux nièces de lougansk qui
gouvernent mais je vous dis justement
jure jean paul ii s'annonce rude
je suis bien là
j'ai parlé des marionnettes de kremlin
pourquoi c'était face c'était fascinant
de militaires soyez sens premier et
deuxième corps de l'armée deux dernières
dallaire il est subordonné à l'état
major russe ils sont dirigés par les
officiers russes notamment joueurs des
dieux du district et su de base et
ils sont dirigés par des officiels us
qui viennent en rotation il ya des
snipers et à tous les toutes les forces
spéciales lui ce qui vient qui font
qu'ils font leurs entraînements vous
savez les artisans russes et pour passer
leur examen final ils viennent en
ukraine pour tirer sur les sous les
positions de l'udc ou non c'est pas faux
du mensonge non pas du tout
diaby à j'ai pas dans les terminaux
de le wiki constater la
non vie d'amasser les armes et
de les intégrer jours sur l'île sont les
troupes
13000 mon équipe est parlé par telus ces
amendes ou ce qu'ils soient là bas ils
sont ils sont intéressés à cette équipe
et par le roman russe nous sous le nom
mais c'est l'argument
économique et des prix sur justement
cette question des accords de minsk moi
ce que j'ai lu sélectivement c'est que
la russie et l'ukraine se renvoient un
peu la balle sur la responsabilité de la
non application de ces accords
finalement est-ce que ce sont pas
simplement qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord
sur les modalités de cet accord n'ont
écouté man
je suis interrogé qui va répondre sur ce
point la responsabiliser sont
exclusivement russe est effectivement
vrai que sur certains points la partie
ukrainienne n'a pas toujours fait preuve
d'une sévérité dans la mise en oeuvre la
rapidité dans la mise en oeuvre qui qui
la rendent absolument il honte de toute
faute nathan non je crois qu'il faut
quand même en même temps à dire les
choses comme elles sont s'il n'ya pas
d'application de beats 2 c'est avant
tout parce que parce que cette partie
occupée des forces au port russe avec le
soutien ouvert et direct de la russie
donc si ces fameuses accord de règlement
en tout cas de règlement pas s'il est la
question ils se sont impliqués je dirais
que c'est peut-être aux deux tiers aux
trois quarts de la cause de la russie et
peut-être
du côté
emmanuel mâcon a proposé de réunir de
nouveau le fameux format normandie au
niveau des conseillers
ces jours ci à paris moi ce que je
regarde en tout cas c'est que moscou ya
déjà trois mois littéralement torpillé
le processus normandie en publiant la
correspondance diplomatique des
ministères allemands craignent un et est
français parce que ça qu'on veut savoir
des initiatives il ya vraiment pas mieux
c'est une manoeuvre quasiment inédite
donc je ne sais pas si l'ukraine ne
croit encore ces deux mais en tout cas
ce que je sais c'est que la russie
apparemment a décidé de le jeter le
processus à la poubelle verrons si on
peut le sortir une belle alexandre orlov
je vais sortir de la poubelle je suis
écouté les voix pour venus voir ce qu on
leur dira que le processeur arm andy a
été rouvert aujourd'hui à paris l isi
non c'est vraiment n'importe quoi le
processus de normandie a été lancée en
2015 par la signature de ces accords est
d'ailleurs je voudrais rappeler que la
russie fait pas partie de l'accord et
les garants de ces accords et les cet
accord a été signé entre président de
l'ukraine porochenko et les dirigeants
de données est de lugano
et je pense à vous laisser je voulais
juste une chose aussi une manière
là aussi à violer d'une manière
flagrante les accords de mise en
distribuant des passeports russes aux
citoyennes de ce territoire ya plus de
cinq cent mille personnes qui sont déjà
des passeports russes c'est une
violation flagrante des accords de minsk
bernard guetta justement alors puisque
le dialogue au sein du cadre normandie a
repris aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya
to them as désaccord profond sur ces
accords de minsk est ce qu effectivement
ils peuvent être une nouvelle base de
négociation
mais côté c'est très simple si la russie
veut réellement
que ces accords soit appliquée et
ensuite pouvoir retirer ses troupes et
cesser ces menaces de guerre mais c'est
très simple que la russie fasse preuve
de bonne volonté et évidemment que
l'ukraine à ce moment là ne pourra que
suivre dans cette bonne volonté russe
mais je voudrais faire une observation
plus générale et est dit devant monsieur
orlov que si j'étais citoyens de la
fédération de russie je ne pourrais
vraiment plus avoir confiance dans le
président poutine car il nuit
systématiquement aux intérêts nationaux
de son pays j'en donne
quatre ou cinq exemples en vrac
premièrement la biélorussie a toujours
été profondément philo russe fil aux
russes la visuel russie grâce à la
politique de monsieur poutine est en
train de devenir russophobe exactement
comme grâce à monsieur poutine l'ukraine
est devenu russophobe le la géorgie le
kazakhstan la kirghizie l'arménie extra
tous ces pays sont déstabilisés et
deviennent russophobe grâce à la
politique de monsieur poutine et puis
maintenant nous avons la cerise sur le
gâteau monsieur poutine est en train de
ramener en europe les etats unis qui
voulait s'en aller pour se consacrer à
leur bras de fer avec la chine et
monsieur poutine est en train merci
monsieur poutier de serrer les rangs des
27 pays de l'union européenne
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous pourrez
répondre à ce que justement poutine
n'est pas en train de jeter l'ensemble
de ses états dans les bras de l'otan les
affameurs de minsk ont été reconnus par
le président mâcon le chancelier
allemand
les accords de
ouagadougou
est ce que est ce que la politique de
vladimir poutine je reprends ce qu'il
vient de dire ne pousse pas en ce moment
l'ukraine et d'autres pays même la fere
land maintenant on commence à dire
qu'elle a envie de rentrer dans l'otan
excuse pas cette politique justement ils
représentent une menace ces différents
pays à rentrer dans le temps un livre
qui se respecte alors doit exécuter les
engagements qu'il a pris l'ukraine a
signé ces accords alors il y à l'épi
garant la france l'allemagne la russie
il faut respecter ces accords ce sont
les accords de musique voulez
là tout le reste est inventé
spécialement
oui sauf à la russie exige un engagement
écrit pardonnez-moi de nos élargissement
de l'otan à l'ukraine et à la géorgie
est également un retrait des forces de
l'ensemble des pays de la loire s'ils
ont adhéré à l'otan en 1999 parce que
nous avons constaté depuis des années
des années que l'on nous on triche avec
nous et chaque fois qu'on dont les
engagements oraux on ne tient pas c'est
pour ça que nous allons d'ailleurs tous
les systèmes de la sécurité des années
70 80 a été basée sur le traité sur les
accords et on a vécu un sécurité
aujourd'hui tous ces accords ont été
dénoncées par les etats-unis et par le
temps il y à un vide dans le domaine de
la sécurité et c'est pas vladimir
poutine qui a provoqué ce non pas du
tout voilà des murs portes il est plutôt
victime il est plutôt la politique et
les deux américains de l'otan bruno
tertrais votre réaction est-ce qu
effectivement déjà pour revenir sur la
politique américaine est ce que les
américains pour avancer un peu
sanctionnerait vraiment la russie telle
qu'ils ont annoncé qu'ils le feraient en
l'occurrence on la sent en l'excluant de
swift de l'ensemble donc des dotations
financières édition
mais il faut toujours marly que les
américains là il s'agit des américains
et les européens ne se passera rien sans
que les deux soient punis de manière
assez inouï je trouve ce sens
qu'américains et européens avec quelques
nuances sur vraiment tous sur la même
ligne pour dire il est absolument
inacceptable qui est une agression une
nouvelle agression russe contre
l'ukraine et la riposte sera sévère et
pas ce sévère ça ne veut pas dire
forcément une pause militaire et
finalement on voit patrick elle est
aussi une personne n'a envie d'attaquer
la russie mais là les sanctions seront
sans le terrible pour la russie le
pouvoir russe pour les oligarques russes
la question du système swift ce système
d'échangés interbancaires ça fait partie
des discussions mais les américains qui
décident et petit rappel suis-je était
basé en belgique donc il s'agit pas de
dire les américains n'ont nous dessinons
ensemble et je dois dire que là pour le
coup l'administration buydens étrange
beaucoup avec les messages en train de
vraiment la jouer le jeu les
consultations et franchement je le
rappelle moi je suis assez profit de
voir le degré d'unité il peut y avoir
entre européens et avec les américains
sur ce sujet malheureusement si parmi
six
bien compris mais si la russie devait
avancer déstabiliser le court en
craignant par des moyens militaires ou
autres de manière de manière agressive
là je n'ai vraiment pas le choix
d'autres choix que de réagir de manière
immédiate et massive contre la contre
l'état russe est plutôt montre le
pouvoir russe et évidemment nous
n'allons rien contre la population russe
bien au contraire la russie
n'aurait-elle pas beaucoup à perdre si
effectivement il y avait une incursion
que en ukraine écoutez la russie depuis
1945 vis ou les sanctions des
occidentaux cela n'a pas empêché là
aussi de se développer d'envoyer le
premier homme dans l'espace et d'être
une grande puissance donc
ça nous fait rire toutes ces menaces de
sanctions madame et la russie n'a aucune
intention d'envahir l'ukraine non pas
parce que la peur de qui que ce soit ma
parce que c'est pas son intérêt là aucun
intérêt d'envoyer l'ukraine au chaos que
l'ukraine reste dans sa zone d'influencé
va faire tout son possible pour ça nous
craignent peut pas changer sa géographie
on est là c'est notre voisin nous allons
que ce voisin soit pas la menace contre
nous et laref coup washington la réponse
écrite qu'on connaît un tout petit peu
justement qui parle encore normal de
l'otan
donc vous attendez d'en connaître
vraiment les détails avant mais les
diplomates c'est différent à deux
journalistes a pour porter son jugement
il faut voir les textes on
s'adore justement puisque vous parlez de
diplomatie qu'est ce que serait prête à
faire la lumière poutine quelles
concessions parce que finalement si on
parle de compromis c'est ça la
diplomatie il faut que chacun accepte
une forme de concession justement cette
concession c'est quelque chose qu'on
négocie et on peux pas vous dire l'avant
ce qu'est ce que va céder poutine sibide
insead quelque chose
il faut trouver le compromis d'intérêt
c'est ça le sens de la diplomatie
et moi je pense aux parisiens ya cet
échange de projets et de la réponse
écrite constitue déjà une base pour
poursuivre le dialogue qui peut aboutir
un jour à des accords qui vont garantir
la sécurité des uns et des autres c'est
ce que recherche monsieur poutine c'est
ce que recherche monsieur bernard guetta
mort
en 2008
je m'en félicite évidemment je m'en
félicite mais je voudrais rappeler à
l'ambassadeur orlov une chose qui peut
leur assurer qu'ils devraient leur
assurer
au sommet de l'alliance atlantique à
bucarest la france et l'allemagne ont
mis leur véto publiquement à une entrée
de l'ukraine dans l'alliance atlantique
il n'y a aucune actualité d'une
quelconque entrée de l'ukraine dans
l'alliance atlantique alors pourquoi est
ce que monsieur poutine fait semblant
aujourd'hui de s'en inquiéter
alors que cette possibilité n'existe pas
bon on va terminer donc ce débat par une
question la vôtre bernard guetta merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous alexandre
orlov à monsieur l'ambassadeur merci à
vous voulez des me reposer merci bruno
tertrais d'avoir été avec nos diamants
et merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous sur france 24